hey guys it's me Ali Brooke I'm here at
BuzzFeed a typical day in the life of me
is when I wake up I go into hair and
makeup
I love my team shout out for them in my
clan team I love you get dressed and
then I head off to the first interview
so I'll be in the car with my team and
then we go to each every stop for like
eight hours eight to ten hours what I
love about doing press stays especially
now is now that I'm a solo artist it's a
whole different meaning and life so I'm
able to talk about my art in my journey
my process and how excited I am about
the record and each and every stop that
I've been to has been so amazing
everybody loves the song and that makes
me happier than ever
[Music]
filming the music video was such a
special experience I walked on that set
and seeing all the people kind of
gathered there I was there with my dad
he was able to come to the music video
set and we were both just in awe and I
definitely shed some tears so that was
one of the best days of my life
my mom my dad and my brother they've
been a part of every single step you
know those moments of frustration those
moments of discouragement this moments
of Tears of not knowing if anything will
ever happen literally there's not a day
that goes by that I don't talk to my
parents
[Music]
I think it was such an amazing learning
experience of how the businesses in the
industry is and how fast-paced
everything is I was really prepped for
music videos and and red carpets
interviews traveling tour I got so much
experience from that and what that feels
like so it kind of helped with being a
solo artist I feel like everybody's kind
of in their own world right now so we
don't really talk as much but of course
I can support each other and like we'd
be liking each other's posts and and
kind of seeing online what we're doing
in sometimes we'll slide into each other
stems well I feel like right now it's
such a different space for me this is my
first single to come out so now people
start to know me and they'll start to
know me because one of the lyrics is you
should really get to know me yeah weird
I thought is really cool you know it
just all feels like me so I'm having a
blast because I'm genuinely doing what I
love to do
[Music]
I am so excited like honestly ecstatic
that my first single is dropping like
that's a huge moment I found out that my
music video is going to be played no not
only once but twice in the middle of
Times Square but I found that out I
serve crying leading up to this moment
has been so many tears and so much hard
work and perseverance so much of
believing in myself and it's such a
beautiful moment only for me but for my
family so I'm so excited about that
honey give me that line give me that
what is it called up you don't know why
I just getting hahaha
but sometimes yes but I love to just be
in big bed with like cats watching that
flicks talk to my family on the phone I
love to eat so whatever her eating and
Falls what I hope to do is I want to
make people of all ages and all over the
world feel confident feel good about
themselves I want them to hear my record
and to feel like they can sing it and
they can dance to it and just have no
inhibitions but just be in the moment
and I just want to make people happy and
feel good about themselves so that's the
goal and I I just want to entertain
[Music]
maybe have an album out a year from now
would be so cool I'd love to go on some
sort of tour any time that I can perform
in front of people is an amazing amazing
thing especially if it's my own music
and people sing back to it and they like
it oh I'm really really really looking
forward to that and bringing my visions
to life on the stage because I've never
ever been able to do that so those are
the main things I'm really excited
[Music]